Mexico is one of the deadliest countries
for journalists last year alone
ten journalists were killed apparently
as retribution for their work especially
at risk are those who dare to ask
questions about Mexico's drug cartels
the country's war on drugs has claimed
tens of thousands of civilian lives in
the past two decades journalist
Annabelle Hernandez is a survivor her
family has been threatened at gunpoint
and someone once left a box of
decapitated animals on her doorstep her
popular 2010 book narco land
investigates ties between drug cartels
and the Mexican government
she says her work has put her life at
risk many officials of the Mexican
government tried to kill me notice in a
law a cartel no chapo guzman was the
Mexican government who tried to kill me
as have been trying to kill too many
other journalists in Mexico that are
trying to say that true about this
collusion Hernandez now lives in exile
in Europe where she continues her
research for her efforts to expose
corruption Deutsche Welle has awarded
her the 2019 freedom of speech award
well this award came in a very sensitive
the moment in my in my life because
outside from Mexico I feel very alone I
feel I feel lonely but this award for me
is a kind of much more than a war
a solidarity on a visit to Mexico the
Director General of Deutsche Welle
explained the decision to award the
prize to Hernandez she stands for a lot
of Mexican journalists who have a really
difficult job here in a country where
corruption and narcos criminality is
very high to do there
job and I think so it's a well-deserved
hall award for her and for all Mexican
journalists Hernandez hopes to return to
Mexico one day to be closer to her
family she was glad to see Mexico's new
administration take a stance against
government corruption but she believes
it will take courageous deeds not just
words to pull her country back from the
brink